yo what's going on guys christy flakes
here of bleacher report and for today's
video we are checking out one question
every nba team needs to answer at the
trade deadline that's an article by
grant hughes so the way we are going to
be handling this one right here is we're
going to go through like 10 of the more
interesting questions and i'm going to
you know read what grant has to say
compare his answers to mine it's gonna
be a great time man so yes uh let me
know in the comment section below if we
come up across the question of your
favorite team give me an answer to it
man because you know i love reading all
your guys's comments and just really you
know your outlook at your favorite team
and kind of your mindset going into the
nba trade deadline uh so the first one
we're gonna look at is actually the
boston celtics and this is should the
celtics overhaul now or later so you
know based off the article right here um
graham's kind of stating that you know
he wants them to take a more immediate
action type of approach just because
you know in this case between like al
horford and dennis shooter and you know
even marcus smart who could um get you
some pretty good trade assets right
there uh it's a chance for the celtics
to do something right now on the current
you know season they are 26 and 25 um a
pretty average team which is saying a
lot for a team that has jason tatum and
jaylen brown now in my opinion uh i also
agree that they should take some sort of
action especially with like dennis
schruter because as it stands right now
the celtics are like they're pretty mid
they're a pretty mid basketball team so
i mean when you have shooter who is
better than what he's getting paid
right now you want to flip that and get
something that can help you out in the
future now i will say if that immediate
action uh involves trading away jason
hayden or jaylen brown i'm probably
against that just because you know
having like financial flexibility within
the next few seasons and stuff like that
i want them to be able to go after that
third piece or maybe even just a slew of
pieces to put around tatum and jalen
brown i still really believe in those
two guys is the core for a basketball
team um i just think they need to build
around them in a different way that
might be a good opportunity you know in
the short term to set them up for
long-term success uh the next team we
are going to be checking out is the
charlotte hornets
and this is what's miles turner worth so
you know looking at it right here man um
it's no doubt that
the charlotte hornets they need to
upgrade at center you know granite
state's right here about how when they
have pj washington in the game like that
small ball lineup just doesn't really
work i mean in my opinion pj washington
is more of a powerful than he is a
center um mason plumlee is pretty
average like in my opinion he is like
the definition of an average center when
you add miles turner that's a 610 player
that can stretch the four block shots
and just gives you know a multi
offensive tool for lamela ball to work
with out there um but also at the same
time
you know i think it's i think it's
important to know they did bring up pj
washington who is available because i
think that pj washington actually is
like the perfect type of player for the
pacers to go after now i think to get
miles turner includes more than just pj
washington but like i said pj kind of is
like a smaller miles turner and who's on
the patients already that plays with
miles turner it's a bonus so bonus plays
the fourth spot so turner can play the
five i would love the idea of sabonis
played the four i'm sorry if you played
the five spot which i think he is uh a
better center than his power forward and
having pj washington who has the same
style of game as miles turner but at
that four spot it just makes a lot of
sense and uh also there's been rumors of
the pacers being interested in like
gordon hayward in the past so it might
be an opportunity for charlotte to get
their guy
in having miles turner but the pacers
also being able to like retool their
team around some bonus in a way that
just makes more sense from a mobility
and a skill set standpoint so yes uh
next up we are going to be checking out
the chicago bulls and this is is patrick
williams a core piece and uh looking
what grant has to say right here um you
know he's he's wondering if in the short
term
is patrick williams the guy because it
appears that you know williams could be
back actually before um the playoffs and
everything like that but
is keeping a guy like that who has so
much potential as opposed to going for a
guy like a jeremy grant listed here is
that a better move for a team that's in
win now mode like this bulls team has
been brought together so nicely
uh to the point that i think it's a fair
question to ask because when it comes
down to patrick williams and just his
potential as a basketball player i do
think he has all-star you might even say
superstar potential man like he's got
that nba body he's got the athleticism
but he's still a few years away from
that so
if patrick williams right now
can buy into a role of being you know
that fourth option on the team when he
comes back healthy he can focus on
making the hustle plays being the glue
guy for a basketball team and um you
know just being that difference maker
which for a contender that's so
important to have then i think that in
the short term
you don't consider that like a core guy
but a very important guy to the uh to
the team with the mindset of okay
patrick williams you know you know come
to my office let's talk about your
future role at this team in the future
we see you as an all-star player but
right now you know we have to kind of
view you more as
a supporting cast piece so i think the
coreness of it comes down to patrick
williams and his mindset of what he
wants now but also in the future and
buying into the system right so yes
right here uh even talking about trading
um uh grant asks you know are is patrick
williams and kobe white too much to
surrender for jeremy grant you know a
guy like that right now or not enough
just because jeremy grant is that type
of player that can bring you defense in
that offensive mindset right now but uh
if i'm being quite honest
i would rather keep patrick williams as
a bulls fan just because jeremy grant we
know that his mind says he wants to be
like a top scoring option on a
basketball team wherever he goes to
assuming he doesn't say with detroit
pistons and that's not what the bulls
need right now because they they don't
need that offensive guy they got you
know they got derozan they got zach
levine they got vucevic they need a guy
that can bind to the system and be a
glue guy so i think it really comes down
to patrick williams becoming that um and
i think that's the best way to kind of
look at it in my opinion uh next up we
are going to go with the detroit pistons
and this is going to be here we go man
how high can we drive the asking price
of jeremy grant so
you know going back to like the bulls
and stuff like that um there was talks
of kobe white patrick williams uh what
we got here man says can the pistons pit
suiters against one another possibly
inflating grant's value beyond what the
orlando magic got for aaron gordon um so
i would say as far as his trade value
for one you gotta find that perfect fit
you know you gotta find that team that
will allow him to be a second or third
scoring option i mean i guess he wants
to be the primary guy but that's just
it's not a good idea like that's not
going to lead to like championships
which should be the ultimate goal uh but
at the same time as far as asking price
you know was recently reported that
jeremy grant wants like a four-year 100
million dollar extension as a piston fan
i am all for giving him that like that
is a great contract it's a very tradable
contract and it's not asking for you
know much more than the 20 million
dollars he gets a season right now so i
mean
if i'm the pistons i'd be a little
greedy i'd be a little greedy you know
see what people want for him uh see what
the you know what the offers are
uh as far as he goes i mean
i like the idea of getting a young asset
and maybe a draft pick or something like
that i don't want to get too crazy with
that i do think there is to be a realm
of realism with it but uh i also
wouldn't settle for like a bad trade
like thd and kendrick nut or something
like that like i would not take that as
a pistons fan hang on to him with the
mindset that you could get a really good
deal for him but if not then you can
sign a great basketball player back for
four years 100 million dollars on a team
that he actually wants to be a part of
right now at that point you have to talk
about like the future of how he fits in
with guys like kate cunningham and if he
can be more that second third option guy
but i think his asking price as far as
the contract goes makes the pistons not
in an immediate situation where they
have to trade this guy away plus he
still has one more year after this
season at 20 million dollars so yeah
definitely no rush there whatsoever um
next up we are going to look at to the
golden state warriors
should we be this attached to james
wiseman so let's kind of read through
this real quick here man um it says
the needle thread plan uh depends
largely on weizmann who remains in seven
foot question mark in the second season
bad hands poor feel and stunted
understanding of schemes on both ends
made for a rough rookie season which is
easy to happen especially as a center
like the center position has changed so
much over the years so really
understanding how you fit not only on a
basketball team but also a great team
like the golden state warriors i could
see where weisman didn't want to like do
too much right away like you don't want
to take away from what makes the
warriors great it says his physical
tools are tremendous wiseman is a
legitimate center who can run and uh
change direction like a guard yeah i
would say maybe he can be like that
you know deandre 18 type of player for
the suns but even with a little like
more like mobility that you might get of
a guy like marvin bagley or somebody
like that so it is very exciting what
wiseman potentially could be
but i'm also in the mindset too that you
know how the warrior system runs and the
window they have open right now their
window has never relied heavily on
having an offensively dominated center
they've always dealt good with having
guys that can play that role player type
of role and uh play great defense that
hard screens you know what kevin looney
did or you know javel mcgee or even
andrew bogut going a few years back and
i think wiseman to blossom into the
player he can be
it's either gonna take him being patient
you know for many years on the warriors
or it's gonna be him being traded you
know to a team that can really focus on
him right now i just don't think it's
the warriors and i don't think that's
wrong with the warriors to do that
um i mean look at their record man like
they're they're in contention right now
so you're not going to cater towards a
second year player um at the stake of
risking a championship run so i think
there's definitely some room there to
maybe consider you know moving on from
wise men for more win now type of
players and i think that's okay to do uh
next up we are going to go with the los
angeles lakers and this is going to be
where is our wing stopper well i'm gonna
tell you where he's at he's on the
washington wizards and his name is kcp
uh they gave up a lot to get russell
westbrook i mean in the moment it didn't
seem like a lot because
it was like role player type of guys
that were giving up for westbrook but i
mean you know i think it just goes to
show how guys like kuzma and kcp were so
important to this lakers squad now there
is opportunities out there to make some
type of trade um
you know to get that winged
type of guy out there but also
yeah as you say it's really like trevor
roose's past is prime so
thc kendrick none being the best trade
chips i mean
uh it's gonna
it's gonna take the the right type of
trade to make this happen like hey like
thc is a good player he's a good
basketball player he's got good
potential everything like that and
realistically like with his like long
wingspan he could be that wing stopper
but that still might be a few years away
so
um could they get somebody like a paul
millsap or something like that in the
buyout market yes very well so but at
the same time like paul millsaps past
his prime so i mean the bio market is
going to be a case of it's just going to
be giving more like old players that
maybe can play like a specific role but
also not exactly what the lakers need
right now so i think it's gonna be about
you know finding that right fit in the
tht type of trade i don't know what that
looks like exactly you guys let me know
in the comment section below
but uh definitely something to be
addressed
all right next up we do have the
timberwolves and this is gonna be can we
be realistic about d'angelo russell so
here we go let's read this uh it says uh
now is the time to move danger also when
his on off splits are at the all-time
high and his defense has gone from trash
bag to mixed bag okay okay it won't be
easy the wolves have a ton of expiring
salaries and all their future restaurant
picks to dangle without a third team
involved that most certainly won't be
enough to get ben simmons okay so this
is talking about moving on from d-lo and
training him you know for more of a
necessity with the team like between
carl finney towns and anthony edwards
you have a lot of offense right there
you have a lot of offense um even like
the defense especially like start the
season stuff that like the t wolves
actually had like a top defensive team
or whatnot so i mean
um i i do get the mindset right here uh
i also like d law a lot i feel like he's
found a nice home with the t wolves i
feel like they're
really building a good foundation to the
point where
they don't need to trade d-lo anthony
edwards or cats they just need to get
the right guys around them like i feel
like that's a very fair core to have i
feel like their games complement each
other very nicely so
i don't know if i would move on from d
low personally speaking i mean i guess
if they want to take a chance on a guy
like a ben simmons maybe you look into
doing that but uh i know there was just
you know just talks of even bringing in
like a jeremy grant or like a defensive
wing player like that to put in xdk i
think is very intriguing i've saw trade
rumors of you know guys like miles
turner playing alongside catch um i
think there's ways to improve this team
without giving up the core three and uh
as somebody that's a big fan deangelo
russell he brings to the team i'm happy
for him finding success with the team
and uh the people's and gender i find
myself rooting for them so yeah man all
right next up we do have the new york
knicks and this is can we stay patient
so it says patience has never been the
new york knicks defining quality which i
think by looking at that statement alone
it shows that yes the knicks need to be
patient and the best example i can bring
up right here is actually zach levine he
was just on a podcast the other day
talking about tom thibodeau and how he
was you know when he was the uh
president of basketball operations or
whatnot for the timberwolves and how
impatient they got with the core of
carlton towns andrew wiggins and uh zach
levine it just wasn't really giving like
a good solid chance to blossom into
things to the point where we look back
now it's like damn that's like three
ulcers that was right there so with the
knicks
you know it's the same case where this
season they're struggling but you know
let's not put themselves in a bad
financial situation trying to do a quick
fix right i mean look at what you have
you have rj bear you have mitch robinson
you have emanuel quickly you have you
know good young players that need to
come together now if you don't think
julius randle is the man to have then i
think that's a discussion to be had or
even like obi top i don't even mention
him man like there's a good young core
on this knicks team and it's going to
take time to blossom don't get impatient
and put yourself in a bad financial
situation to have a quick fix
uh next up we do have the philadelphia
76ers who wants to buy his harris a team
that wants to buy his harris needs to
have first
their number one number two guy on the
team needs to be you know young players
on rookie contracts or small contracts
to the point where you can absorb a guy
to buy his harris in the short term it's
not going to affect what you're able to
do with your team um in the short term
so that's kind of a difficult type of
situation to have right here
uh it says yeah for philly to have any
real shot at james harden they would
need to trim
um off harrah's which is very true the
guy's got a very large contract so i
think it's really all about finding that
right situation of a team that could use
tobias who is overpaid but that does not
make him overrated he's still a great
basketball player so there's a fit out
there i mean i don't know what it is
exactly but it's got to exist it's got
to exist all right next up we do have
the portland trailblazers uh what form
will the rule will the uh
form i'm sorry what form will the rule
feeling
you know i can't talk man what form will
the re-tooling take man okay that's uh
that's a tongue twister right there uh
damian lillard isn't going anywhere
that's a good way to look at it right
there off the bat so we know damien's
not going anywhere like that's
they still believe in this man we also
have seen ifrene simons which i did not
expect him to jump off this quickly as a
player so you have that combined with uh
having the trade assets of cj mccollum
which it's just reported that like teams
like the pelicans have been interested
in him you have nerf issues you can
trade roko there is ways to retool with
the mindset of building that team around
damian lillard but also on freddie
simons heaven simons and just how
quickly he's become this good is
exciting like it allows you to do new
things now and kind of look at things
from a different perspective as a gm of
the portland trailblazers and then
finally the last team we're going to
talk about sacramento kings is dear fox
a cornerstone
i do not think
that based off what we've seen so far
that darren fox is the number one option
on a championship team he's a second
option in some circumstances third
option in a lot of cases too man so i
think the kings can view him as a part
of the championship puzzle but not the
main piece so as far as what they want
to do to convince a star to you know be
that number one scoring option next to
dear fox um they have the assets to do
it it's just all about convincing and
you know really going for that big guy
and forget to see your via the trade
deadline whatever it may be man but uh
yes that is all we have for this video
today hopefully you guys all enjoyed
this i'm gonna go scroll through the
bottom right here just so you guys can
see every single team and uh like i said
man give me your thoughts and opinions
in the comment section below thank you
all so much for watching and peace out
my friends